you're watching the GameSpot co-op stage
sponsored by Lego Star Wars The Force
awakens
everybody welcome to e3 2016 on the
GameSpot co-op stage I'm one of your
hosts Greg Miller from kind of funny
alongside the pride of Long Island from
kind of funny Col Moriarty the beer over
there Chris waters from GameSpot calm
hello and right here David cage David
Kane you son of a [ __ ] to that game
look at that peasant opera so let me
shake your hand
Oh Detroit become human good lord sir I
you know what a fan of heavy rain I was
and I let you owe me into a false sense
of confidence because when I saw this is
the demo you see car I was like oh she's
the playable character totally makes
sense and then here we go another AI
pops top and we're gonna be playing as
him not only are there more are there
more playable characters is it that much
like heavy rain what's happening who
knows god Detroit Oh - oh my god too
long I mean these games take a crazy
amount of time just to be put together
so so what's it like then to come out of
the night to come out but have the video
come out at PlayStation and show
something brand new and take people by
surprise oh well yeah we we and as you
said we announced the game at the Paris
games week and as you know it was
inspired by the short that we did before
in 2012 I think where we introduced this
character of Cara with an Android coming
to life and it was very interesting
because people really enjoyed the short
and they wanted to know what would
happen to Cara once you leave the
factory and I didn't have a clue so this
is how everything started and I just
needed to imagine the story from there
that was the starting point for gear for
Detroit when you made the short did you
imagine your next game was going to be
something completely different I see I'm
solely now because actually when we
worked on the short it was just supposed
to be a technical demo I just needed to
write something very quickly because we
wanted to test how far we could go with
emotions and so the
facts words let's write something where
we have a character going through very
different emotions in five minutes so
that was the holder of the specs and
this is how I rode the short and then I
wanted to expand this story and I was
really haunted by this question what
happens to Cara that where does she go
yeah when she leaves the factory and we
started working on Detroit that way and
I thought that maybe one character was
great but I wanted to go back to somehow
what I did on heavy rain telling a story
from different perspectives with
different characters through different
eyes and here we are at these
reproducing our second character called
Connor now great name now the question
then for me becomes is is the story that
they're all mixed up in more than just
our our androids alive is there like a
more is there and of course we have the
origami killer and heavy rain that was
like unified all the different parts is
this one just about Android rights or is
there more to it well we tried to create
a very complex story through multiple
characters and of course the story
starts separated so you start playing
Keira and the next scene is going to be
with Connor and maybe who knows maybe
there are other characters but of course
all the stories will blend and tell the
big story okay so yeah we this this
format allows us to talk about many
different things many different topics
and what we want to do with detroy is
not so much to create another story
about AI or technology we want to talk
about human beings we want to talk about
us about our society about our present
our past maybe our future but we want to
talk about human emotions that's the
most important thing for us so that was
one very important thing and when in the
writing and the second important thing
was to say there's been many stories
where we they were taking the point of
view of humans and saying our androids
are the bad thing there are the virus
and they want to destroy us and we need
to win and I just wonder what would
happen if they were the good guys
and maybe the humans are the bad guys
maybe we are in a decline Society maybe
we become dealt selfish maybe we become
more dependent to technology what if
they were the right
the right thing yeah tell me about about
Detroit as a setting because in the
United States
Detroit has looked at frankly as a very
as a hyper decaying City a city that's
being abandoned basically I noticed that
in the it looked like to me that GM
towers for instance are they're like
what the city's been revitalized can you
talk a little bit about the reality of
Detroit during the setting like how what
happens is it that that AI becomes the
new car manufacturing base there well
you know I'm French and maybe I have a
different perspective on the city and
the eastery of Detroit but I was very
fascinated by the story of the city that
was a big Titan of the 20th century and
went through hard times and I thought it
if the Android industry had to be born
somewhere they would probably need huge
factories and a lot of space and then
just go somewhere and I thought a
Detroit would be the perfect place for
that but it's also a great city for its
cultural background music is fantastic
in Detroit of course there is Motown and
many artists were born there and there's
a lot going on so we traveled to Detroit
because we didn't want to write about a
city from Paris you see what I mean so
we spent a lot of time there of course
taking pictures and we visited the
abandoned factories and the abandoned
churches but at the same time we met the
people and we we were very surprised by
the energy there and the fact that there
is there are people want to build
something new here and there's a lot of
energy and there's definitely something
happening in Detroit that's that's how
we felt when we went there and I thought
that all this combined made it the
perfect background for the story that I
wanted to tell that was really it's a
very human story Detroit's as a city
it's a very human story it was the
perfect background from my story thanks
Chris we're hogging them talk to David
cage well you know I cage all day long
shouldn't we all what I'm curious about
is you know you have heavy rain you've
got a couple different characters that
the player is spreading they're sort of
agency between then you go to beyond and
it's really just the two and now with
Detroit you're spreading it back out
beyond more than two characters I'd
imagine what have you sort of learned
from that narrowing of focus with beyond
that you're carrying through to how
you're giving the player agency across
multiple characters in Detroit well you
know I mean we always try to find the
best way to tell the story we want to
tell and and sometimes it's multiple
characters because we want different
points of view sometimes it's on being
it was logical to tell the story of one
character because we wanted to talk
about different moments in their life
mm-hmm Detroit needed different angles
and because we wanted to tell the story
from different perspectives and just
make this story this individual
individual stories tell the big story
and we also know that people really
enjoy being in the shoes of different
characters and switching from one to the
other and just facing different
situations and different dilemmas and
this is exactly what we want you to
offer them and you know given we were
talking about earlier about the the
character of Detroit the city and sort
of the rejuvenation that you are in the
version you're imagining is to tell the
story of a city you really you do need
those multiple perspectives you need
people in different social strata in
different roles and different places so
it seems like those things intertwine
yeah so Lee it expands the scope it
allows you to tell a bigger story
somehow and yeah that's exactly the type
of tone and intention that we wanted for
this story in particular well speaking
of bigger story you guys had a you know
sort of the trailer the presentation
during the press conference yesterday
you really went at showing a visual
representation of all the branching
dialogue stuff all the branching
opportunities branching ways that you
know Quantic Dream has done so well in
their previous games talk about that
scope and sort of how you're how you're
evolving that system in terms of your
gameplay design and approach well our
ambition for Detroit is really to create
the the most banding story ever created
by the studio so we really want to give
a lot of consequences to play your
actions and basically
we don't want the player just to be the
actor of the of the story we want him to
become the cool writer of the story so
we create this kind of narrative space
and we want the player to play within
this narrative space and tell his own
story through his own decisions and his
own choices and this is really what we
try to do to create so it's it's it's
very complex to write to be honest with
you because it very quickly becomes a
mess yeah I can imagine because there
are tons of things and you want to be
absolutely consistent on the
consequences that you give you want them
to surprise the player but at the same
time to be logical and you want many of
them so we just show one scene and just
just this very first scene as like six
more than six outcomes mm-hmm that will
have an impact later in the game so if
you combine all the scenes together you
realize it can become very quickly very
complex the mind always reels when you
try to wrap your head around what you
know I don't understand how you write it
worried about the platinum trophy
how hard is gonna be to get this
platinum have your in platinum we both
got some heavy rain plans we had to go
it was like it was like a beautiful mind
over there like I was living with all
these things one of the things I'm
always fascinated with you is you guys
really you have a bit of a big name
David cage is a big name monotremes a
big name that you guys make good games I
have I find it impossible to believe
that for other first parties and third
parties have not gone after you for
games why do you keep going back to Sony
what is it about Sony and working with
Playstation that makes you want to like
that makes you wanna stay in that
ecosystem because you could very easily
make multi-platform you know we were we
came here at e3 10 years ago for the
first time with Sony News we came with
this short demo cold the casting that
would become heavy rain later and that
was exactly ten years ago it was in 2006
so we have a very long lasting
relationship with Sony as a publisher
what I personally really enjoy working
with them is the freedom they give me
the creative freedom and yeah that they
support the fact that we try things and
we don't always succeed sometime which
we'll look for something to try
something you know what doesn't work but
that's okay because we try different
things
and that's what I love the most about
them it's their constant support over
the past year 10 years and yeah the fact
that they let us try things and and try
to discover new ideas and what about
Playstations for specifically I mean
it's just the power of this machine is
compared to the ps3 where your other two
weather blaster games live has this
given it has this helped you tell your
story more is it giving you that has the
power really helped you or do you not
necessarily need it like you would need
to make say a Killzone game or something
like that you know I don't think that
you need the best technology to create
emotion I mean you can create emotion
with very simple things actually
technology just make things more real
for sure somehow at least the way you
look at them it also makes everything
more complex in many ways because then
production becomes incredibly difficult
and then you need to scan actors and you
need to have performance capture and you
want the right rendering and lighting
needs to be perfect so it makes
attention to detail that's more
important and but at the same time I
don't think that technology is
absolutely required to create to create
emotion it's just another tool more
colors on your palette but that's it do
you miss when it was simpler when it
wasn't so hard and their shaders and
lighting and scanning and there's a
million things cuz I have to imagine
like you're talking I asked you the
beginning you've been working on it too
long like yeah you know this games
become very complex because yes we have
very high ambition for it and we try to
create something new at the same time
the technology becomes more and more
demanding and I would say that the bad
side of that is that the company is now
200 people so when you work on something
that that tries to be different you have
a vision for it you need to evangelize
this vision across 200 people in your
studio which is more efforts for a game
creator than if we were like 10 working
on the same thing and you know you know
it's it's a very different experience so
I think there are some very good sides
to it because then you have the power
and you can do incredible thing and you
really enjoy doing it at the same time
keeping creative control on what's going
on
sharing excitement and passion in the
studio requires more time and more words
well while we're on the subject of
technology showcased alongside Detroit
at the Sony press conference was psvr so
what firstly David cage as a creator
what are your feelings on VR honestly
when it's before I tried it I was kind
of skeptical thinking okay I see what it
does but and I kept reading people
saying oh it's incredible and I said
okay I'm I need I need to test it so we
check different systems and of course
Morpheus from Sony and I realized that
yeah it's it's really something
different it's really a new platform
it's a new approach to interactivity in
many ways and I think you really need to
see it as a different platform and not
just saying oh can I port my game and
make it work with VR no I think you need
to design for this medium and really
probably think about game design in a
very different way absolutely and I
think one of the most exciting things at
least for me as we get to see all these
sort of VR experiences is quickly sort
of started building your own mental
database of experiences like that how
our developers doing new things here
it's a new it's a new platform it's
almost a new language of game design and
seeing that kind of stuff I mean
definitely puts me in mind of when is
David cage gonna be you couldn't be
giving me some in VR saying I want it
right now no no it's a very interesting
platform but it does it sound challenges
yeah and you really need to find new
answers which is very challenging for
any game creator like okay that's a new
challenge how am I going to solve this
and you need to find new answers because
all the old answers I don't think they
will work on this new platform I agree
David cage oh thank you so much for
coming all right thank you for having me
you said you'd announce the release date
so when is Detroit becoming human coming
up it's not announced yes yeah you
almost had it
rewriting and rewriting quick can you
say that it's 2017 or is that you can't
even say that much what I can say is
that it's not going to be this year okay
cool
that's one year knocked off from here on
out you'll figure out the rest ladies
and gentlemen give it up for David cage
Detroit coming eventually and of course
keep it here on gamespot calm or
youtube.com slash kind of funny games
wherever you're watching this for more a
30 2016 coverage you're watching the
game spot co-op stage sponsored by Lego
Star Wars The Force awakens